In the project at the end of this course,
you'll have the opportunity to demonstrate what you have
learned by creating a data model and Power BI report.
This will combine the major data preparation and modeling concepts taught in this course,
such as cleaning up and transforming data from
multiple data sources to solve a common problem in the real world.
Data Silo is getting in the way of effective decision-making.
Let me set the scene.
You're a junior BI developer who has just been hired by
Seven Sages Brewing Company up near Seattle, Washington.
Seven Sages has a common problem,
they have a lot of data that is not centrally located and they
need help getting everything organized so
they can understand their corporate profitability.
They know that their main flagship beer,
the Bamboo Grove Maibock,
is the most popular,
but it's unclear otherwise,
how much is being sold and what is ultimately the most profitable,
and if some are perhaps even losing money.
There's one more wrinkle with this.
The Seven Sages brewing company is located in Washington state,
but they also sell their beers in British Columbia.
So there's a currency exchange consideration as well,
and they have a fiscal calendar.
So for their data model,
they need to have a fiscal calendar as well as
a standard calendar incorporated into their date table.
We'll go over all the steps you'll need to take to make your data model.
Which in my experience always starts
with really getting a firm understanding of the data,
and as a newer business intelligence professional,
learning how to organize your data into fact,
dimension tables, key columns,
and date tables as well.
We'll also go through a pipeline of how you take
information starting from the initial source,
from a variety of different options.
Pull the information into queries and Power Query so
that you can perform what we call Extract, Transform, and Load.
Then take that information once it's been restructured so that you can organize
it into a data model and ultimately generate the Power BI report that you need.
I designed this project with several of the challenges I've seen
colleagues stumble over or that I've stumbled over myself.
When you're finished with this project,
you'll have demonstrated the ability to create
a highly functional data model that can generate insights by customers and products,
that incorporates currency rates and which accounts for both fiscal and calendar years.